There’s a scene in A Christmas Carol where
a couple charity workers visit Scrooge’s
office looking for donations.
Of course, Scrooge gotta Scrooge, so he kicks
them to the curb.
Ebenezer with all the money in the world, can’t spare
a dime.
That should feel counterintuitive to us, but
as the audience, we nod our heads and think,
“yup, that makes sense.”
Dickens didn’t invent the trope of the cruel,
greedy rich guy, but he sure popularized it,
and there have been countless examples since:
Montgomery Burns, Mr. Potter, Gordon Gekko,
Smaug the Dragon, the Lannisters.
The idea that one’s wealth is inversely
proportional to their empathy is a staple
of fiction, but is there a basis in reality
for it?
Does having more money make you meaner?
And if so, what can be done about it?
If I asked you “why don’t you give away
more money to worthy causes?”, what would you say?
I’d guess we’d all have a response along
the lines of “I don’t have enough money.”
That sounds reasonable on its face.
But what if I told you that research suggests
having more money makes you LESS generous?
A study by the Chronicle of Philanthropy found
households earning 50 to 70 thousand dollars
gave 7.6% of their discretionary spending
to charity.
Those earning $100,000 gave 4.2%.
And those who made over $200,000 and lived
in a zipcode where 40% of their neighbors
earned the same gave only 2.8% to charity.
And a University of Notre Dame survey found
that Americans below the poverty line were
twice as likely to give up to 1% of their
entire income to charity compared to those
above the poverty line.
Researchers at UC Berkeley conducted an experiment
where subjects were asked to rank themselves
on a socio-economic scale from low to high.
Then they were given some cash and asked how
much of it they’d consider giving to a stranger.
Again, people who identified themselves as
lower-class, gave away 44 percent more on
average than their higher ranked counterparts.
Perhaps you’ve heard about the famous “giving
pledge” campaign initiated by Warren Buffet,
Bill Gates, and other billionaires.
In an inspiring move, they are trying to convince
other super wealthy families to give
away half of their fortune over their lifetime.
But, sadly, out of the hundreds of thousands
of ultra-high net worth individuals in the
world, only 187 have signed the pledge in
the 8 years since the campaign started.
There’s no denying there’s a “self-preservation”
streak when it comes to amassing wealth.
Money doesn’t just make us more possessive,
it can also lead to obnoxious, arrogant social behavior.
Take one study that watched
100 random partners play a rigged game of Monopoly.
One of the two players started with double
the starting cash, collected twice as much
when they passed “Go”, and rolled more
dice.
These advantaged players
demonstrated more visible displays of victoriousness
like dominant physical gesturing and loudly
moving their pieces around the board.
They even ate more pretzels that were specifically
located nearer to the disadvantaged player.
When asked afterwards what factors led to
their success, many of them pointed to some
sort of inherent skill rather than the obvious
fact that the game was heavily tilted in their
favor from the start.
It’s like their brains had to find some
sort of self-affirming justification for unearned privilege.
Even pretend-wealth can turn nice Aunt Sharon
into a cutthroat real estate baron!
What’s going on here?
What is it about wealth that can turn even
the best of us into an un-caring Scrooge?
One of the major factors is the connection
between wealth and power.
The greater your wealth, the more advantages
you have in life and the more power you have
over situations, circumstances, and people.
That boost in our sense of power holds a key
to this phenomenon.
In a study at McMaster University, subjects
were split into two groups - one primed to
feel powerful by recounting a situation where
they were in charge - and one was not.
Those feeling more powerful were far less
likely to exhibit what neuroscientists call
“mirroring,” our subconscious copying
of others’ behaviors and moods.
Laughing when others laugh.
Feeling tension in the room when someone says
something inappropriate.
Getting choked up watching someone else cry.
Mirroring is a vital skill that allows us
to adapt appropriately to the people around
us, and fit into social situations.
And it is an essential building block to allowing
us to feel empathy.
If you’re wealthy, or hope to be one day
by watching Two Cents videos, this might be
a bit alarming.
But fear not!
Now that you are aware of some of the dangers
that come along with wealth, there are steps you
can take to build empathy and remain generous
now matter how much money you have.
For starters, don’t isolate yourself or
surround yourself with only your wealthy friends.
Wealthy individuals usually live physically
further apart from others, and when they socialize,
it’s with people at their same income level.
But studies show that wealthy people that
live in economically diverse neighborhoods
give away twice as much to charity than those
that don’t.
So where you live makes a big difference!
And the same guys that did the monopoly study
also found that experiencing nature can make
us more generous.
The feeling of awe when you look up at the
stars or over a vast, expansive landscape
makes you feel less important and therefore
more likely to help someone else out.
So take a hike, Ebenezer!
Wealth isn’t evil.
Or good.
It’s a tool that can impact the world in
ways beneficial... and terrible.
As you journey towards a more prosperous future,
don’t forget to protect yourself from the
emotionally numbing effects of wealth.
For example, you can set a specific percentage
of your income to give away - no matter how
much you make.
And try to actively seek out situations that
will connect you people that aren’t like you.
It’ll help make sure you own your money…
and it doesn’t own you.
And that’s our two cents!
If you give to charity, how do you decide how much? And how do you stick to it?
Let us know in the comments.